hast geschummelt ich habe nicht
geschummelt BR ich einfach gut
investiert du hast 3 € bekommen weil du
und damit hast du dir neue holser
gekauft und das htest du ihr seht schon
ich bin Profi und deswegen freue ich
mich umso mehr euch jetzt das neue
monopoi go vorstellen zu dürfen was
aktuell eines der geheimtesten und
viralsten Spiele in den App Stores ist
Monopoly Go ist eine neue Interpretation
des beliebten Klassikers und ihr findet
viele klassische Elemente wie das wöfen
und die og Spielfiguren wieder jedoch
auch ganz neue Features und innovative
Spielelemente wie beispielsweise den
Aufbau eines imobil Imperiums neben
verschiedenen Minigames und challenges
bietet das Game vor allem coole Events
um mit euren Freunden gemeinsam zu
zocken eines davon ist das Coop Event
spielzeugpartner bei dem ihr bis zum 7
Oktober mit euren Freunden
zusammenarbeiten könnt um Meilensteine
und Belohnungen zu verdienen also ladet
euch das Game jetzt bei den Link in der
Infobox
runter